Every day the world consumes 300 tons of coffee - this amount is enough to give one cup
For every man, woman and child
The world's largest buyer of coffee, the United States has to import almost all this quantity because
Caffeine-growing coffee trees grow only commercially
Cancer orbit and Capricorn orbit in an area called the coffee belt. Only exist
One American state within this belt is Hawaii
However, the United States is the largest buyer because the population is very huge. Most countries
For coffee drinkers per capita are, in ascending order, the Netherlands, Denmark, Iceland
Norway, and Finland champion where they drink three times the coffee
Which the average American drinks daily. All these countries are outside the coffee strap
And to import 100% of its caffeine supply
To get this caffeine, the bees must first correct the flowers of the coffee tree and these flowers
Grow into bright red berries. Unlike more co-plants, the coffee tree
Not all berries ripen at the same time so they need to be picked up
Manually detachable
When you pick up, the coffee bean is removed from the berries. Then it is dried
Heat, grind and drown these plants in hot water to get
The wonderful kaffin. Requires 40 cups of coffee to get one cup of espresso
But why caffeine in coffee beans in the first place? Sure, the coffee trees
You do not want people to cut off parts of them and commit a holocaust
Their offspring
Of course these trees, do not want or feel anything and caffeine evolved in the original
For their own benefit. Caffeine is an insecticide that effectively paralyzes or kills insects that bite
the tree
It is not known if these insects feel the largest caffeine
Caffeine is a killer but adaptive to insects weighing one gram and not for monkeys weighing 100,00
Times are bigger than that. So you have to try to win the Darwin Award
But, if you want to know: calculate the dose of caffeine you need to drink in order to have a fifty percent chance
To die, multiply your weight by 150 mg
Or in terms of coffee, for every kilogram you need to drink one latte
For a visit from the King of Death
This is a lot of coffee and therefore it is expected that there will be no fatalities
They are healthy from this method and it is questionable if possible. Because while
You are busy consuming coffee, your body is busy pulling it out somehow
Rare deaths from caffeine are people who consumed a lot of diet pills or contraception and crazy people
Who consume coffee in its pure form
Although caffeine is not a strong name, you can add to it. It is addictive
The real physiologist is not a rude addiction like addiction to video games
And the Internet
But caffeine is not heroin - the sudden boycott will not kill you - but it may make you cranky
It gives you a painful headache but because caffeine generates dopamine that makes you happy
And get rid of headaches There is no convincing reason to quit the abuse
And who might want to take off anyway? I mean non-converts to Mormonism (hardcore as Wahhabi) and
Rastafarianism. Caffeine is the world's most commonly used drug - and for good reason
It's very cool
It increases concentration, reduces fatigue and gives you better memory
This is not a placebo - these results can be returned to the laboratory
Contrary to popular belief, coffee drink is not a losing deal though
Satan gives you the ability to work quickly but in turn makes your life shorter
For normal, healthy people there are no medical concerns. May give you coffee and caffeine inside
Medical benefits such as protection against cardiovascular disease and diabetes
Parkinson 's disease
Caffeine can get rid of migraines, but the amount is required and the way
Absorption .. uncomfortable
We follow
Do you know what you can thank caffeine for its existence? A small thing called the Age of Enlightenment
In the 1600s people drank beer and jin (alcoholic drink) more than they drank water. But with the advent of coffee
And tea, people changed from a drink gives you depression to a tonic drink. So it is natural that it is in
At that time, a great intellectual civilization was born as compared to previous centuries
Ben Franklin and Edward Lloyd loved the coffee for the same reason as the workers
And today's students to love coffee. It is invaluable because of its ability to make you awake and focused on work when you need to quit
Report what or to remain focused in the boring physics class
Coffee is the fuel of the modern world, so I drink a cup of coffee (no guilt) to give you the motivation to work smartly
And quickly